what I'm going to speak about today is
really sort of following the AIDS
epidemic first in the United States I
think I'll probably given the time spent
most of my talk on the United States and
it also Ron and my experience doing oral
history and the AIDS epidemic in South
Africa the first work that our marshal
alluded to age doctors voices from the
epidemic began around nineteen ninety
one or two I mean this is like the dark
ages i don't remember one year from the
next at this point Ron bear who's my
co-author and colleague and old friend
was at a meeting at the CDC in Atlanta
which was attended by age doctors and
he's an ethicist and political scientist
interested in aids and after the meeting
he went out to dinner with a group of
the AIDS doctors and so it was a bunch
of the guys and gals who had been
involved in the AIDS epidemic at that
point for maybe a dozen years and they
began to trade stories and he's were
like more stories about their
experiences during the hiv/aids epidemic
and ron was slow to fly on the wall
listening to these stories and he was
enthralled he said you know these he's a
wonderful stories and these are
precisely the kinds of tales that will
never be published these these people
adopters they they publish they publish
in the medical journal scientific
articles but these kinds of personal
stories are going to be lost and this
was a time before there was a whole
school of dr. narratives at this point
many physicians are trained to write
narratives but at that juncture in the
early 1990s there were very few example
of doctors writing about the about their
experiences with the epidemic and by and
large when they did they primarily
focused on their patients their
experience with patients and that really
their own emotional and intellectual
psychological experience of the AIDS
epidemic so Ron came back and he's a
political scientist I'm an historian and
he said well what should we do and we
decided we would do this thing called
oral history which we had heard about
and in fact sort of done we were like
the ammonia character mosquitoes rodin
you know we didn't know we were speaking
prose all along because we had we had
done interviews for previous you know
writing but we were lucky enough to know
a run really and Mary Marshall Clark and
we came down and and they really spoke
to us about the project and it reduced
us to oral history and the different
ways in which oral history could be
applied and done so we decided that we
were going to undertake this project
sort of which I have to say is the it
was a real labor of love it was the best
research project I think I've ever
undertaken it was absolutely fascinating
ah but having committed ourselves to the
project we had to decide what we're
going to do obviously we're going to
interview physicians that was our choice
how are we going to select these doctors
and we decided that we would call this
is before we knew email we would call a
small group of doctors in New York
in LA in San Francisco and Chicago who
were different in a number of ways an
sn2 compose a list of physicians that
they thought we should interview we
wanted doctors who had been who had
committed themselves from the beginning
of the AIDS epidemic wherever they were
and more hands-on treaters and we're
still working with patients those are
the kinds of people who want people who
were in the trenches if you will and
they came up with a list of some
overlapping names but about 50 doctors
we started with those 50 doctors of
those 52 only two elected not to be
interviewed so clearly there was a great
interest in the part of these physicians
to to be in whatever book we were going
to be doing and we learned from Mary
Marshall and Ron that we should take
these interviews and we should look
forward to having these interviews
transcribed things that really are so
basic but which we had to learn then we
had to make a number of decisions one of
our concerns was you know as historians
how Frank would doctors be especially an
area of confidentiality doctors are like
you know there's a is a thin white line
just like there's a thin blue line
doctors often don't want to speak ill of
other physicians outside you know to
outsiders and they might not want to
talk about administrators and things of
that kind or things they did which may
be illegal or immoral and yet we wanted
at the same time
to give these doctors we didn't want
these doctors to be anonymous we didn't
want to give them false names either it
just it makes sense to do that I mean
they're sociologists anthropologists
sometimes provide fictional names for
places or people but we thought that
part of the force of the book would be
that you were listening to the voices of
identifiable doctors and in addition a
number of these doctors were extremely
well-known people became famous as a
doctor so once you describe the person
people read the book would know who they
were anyway so what we decided to do was
to be very up to be frank with the
doctors and said look we want you to say
whatever comes to your mind during these
interviews because the interviews will
be transcribed and then we will allow
you to read the transcriptions and if
there are things in the transcriptions
that you you want to remove amend or
sequester for X number of years you're
free to do that so feel free to be frank
with us and I think that they were in
the sense that we have a number of
incredible stories and in fact at one
point using one of the stories we had to
fictionalize a doctor because she talked
about helping a patient to die which was
illegal and she could have gotten a lot
of trouble she's really loud that
transcript to be to be available so we
using the book we hit her her we called
her him and we didn't say wish it was
and that sort of thing
so the other thing that we did think the
other next question to deal with in his
oral history was essentially preparing
ourselves for the interviews now let me
say a little bit about Ron bear run is a
very famous political scientist and
ethicist he is really identified with
the hiv/aids epidemic almost on the
beginning and it's quite an authority on
the ethical issues attended on the
epidemic both he and I became involved
in various ways with the epidemic very
early on about 1983 1984 so we had a
fairly intimate knowledge of the
epidemic we ourselves had gone through
in various ways the stages of the
epidemic and at that point I think even
without research could have done
interviews but the function of research
was not to get research about the
epidemic but really to learn about the
physicians we had a research assistant
and what we tried to do was get every
publication if these doctors had done
studies had published in journals every
mention the press of these people so
that the researcher system could provide
us with a bio of the person we were
going to interview so we and we read all
the scientific articles or were really
felt both emotionally and intellectually
prepared for these interviews and being
prepared that way serves a number of
functions let me let me say that a of
these people there were some who were
quite famous and had been interviewed
many times but the interview many times
by journalists
a journalist often just love questions
at the pathway person or there are
certain cliched questions they ask what
you want to do when you interview or
what I wanted to do when we interviewed
these doctors was have a kind of
credibility that went beyond journalism
that when you sat down with them you
could communicate you could broadcast
the fact that you really knew about AIDS
you really knew about them you knew
about their research you could ask
scientific and personal questions which
were based on this kind of deep
knowledge and I think that was very
helpful in getting them to answer more
fully rather than the way in which they
would respond to two journalists the
other thing you have to ask yourself as
particularly for these doctors who have
been interviewed many times they have
stock answers you may want to ask the
same questions but you don't want the
stock answer and therefore you really
had to think about how you're going to
ask that question in a way that was
different that was a bleak that came at
it in a ridge inul way or probing them
in nicely so that they would go beyond
their wrote answers that was very very
important what we did to prepare also it
was to have a have a questionnaire
excuse me one second while I make sure
my phone is off
we had a questionnaire of about forty
five questions which war standard
questions that we asked of everybody and
then for each of the doctor is based on
that bio our knowledge of them we also a
dance questions that were specific to
those individuals and of course there
were certain questions saud questions
which will be inappropriate for that
person we would not ask those questions
now we knew those questions but when you
go into an interview of the people
you're done oral history notice I what
you're involved in and I think of Cory
run really what I say this is a kind of
controlled conversation you're not going
to go through the list of questions you
may begin with the same questions but
you want to allow the interview to have
its own dynamic its own flow which in a
way allows you to get much more
information and makes you wear things
that you hadn't planned on at all but by
the end of the interview which on
average last about four hours he's a
very intense interviews you had covered
those questions but not in any
particular order one of the things that
was nothing interesting was the purpose
that thing's questionnaire served you
went in with a structure which was often
useful because while some of these
doctors have been interviewed many times
I would say that the majority of the
doctors had never been interviewed they
were not famous they were office space
or Hospital doctors and and basically
they were composing their autobiography
in this in this interview and so the
questionnaire that and the research
allowed you to provide the skeleton
of of this autobiography often this was
the first time that these doctors had
actually spoken to anyone in this kind
of full way about their experiences and
the number of them afterwards actually
wrote wrote of their experiences I think
we actually influenced them to do that
so because it was the first time for
these and because we could ask questions
of leaking of the veterans of interviews
these were very intense interviews said
the average four hours some were you
know probably were actually longer night
in one sitting but longer a very intense
emotional interviews with people talking
about things they had not told their
partners and I told other doctors one
doctor in San Francisco who is basically
totally burnt out you know said to me
was sort of like off tape we're getting
into a car so do you ever talk to other
doctors about the things you've told me
he said you know doctors are lone
Ranger's we don't share these things and
and so these interviews could get a
intimate and quite emotional doctors
speak about the privilege of being
physicians of being of having their
patients to help and things that they
would not tell anyone else and in a way
we had that privilege in that we had
these doctors tell us things that they
probably had told very few people if any
one else and there were moments when the
doctors told us to turn off the tape
because basically they had to recompose
they were they as they talked about
patients as the talk about events they
began to weep the
I began to tremble and they excused
themselves men and women but it was a
very intense and emotional interchange
and to me one of the things I was really
interesting was this is not true of
other doctors have interviewed but
doctors are trained to be in control
even if they don't know what they're
doing they're trained to be in control
and so I thought there would be a
difficulty here and yet in almost all
cases but maybe two that was not so it
was quite remarkable of that once once
we got into the interview something
happened and it was almost always
uniform and maybe other people who've
done if you see this too we would start
with certain stock questions it was just
tell me your date of birth tell me a
little bit about your family and your
education tell you about your training
sort of unoffensive questions of course
the tape is going and and then we start
talking we would have an interchange and
then they came a moment and you could
just I could literally feel it when it's
not like the interview took off if my
analogy is you know when you are lying
in bed and you're tired and you you know
when you're just about going to fall
asleep and then remember nothing more it
just go over that fall I just I just had
that feeling you know there was a point
where this interview is now taking off
the position was no longer conscious of
the fact that I was Jerry Oppenheimer
that he had not well she had not met me
before that I just flown in to Cleveland
a few hours ago we were just sitting in
this room
the person was just having this intense
intimate controlled conversation and
that was really quite quite remarkable
so that to me was was a it was really
quite wonderful and we got an enormous
amount of material a quite frank
material very rich material and I
remember sitting of course of our lives
hawker so one of the things and we had
to learn was to listen we were guys yeah
what can we say but so important to
learn to listen and just sit there and
let me listen with these people are
saying but what the underlying messages
are and knowing you know when they're
hinting that they want to tell you more
and that should you probe is it ethical
to do that and you try it and often it
works and then times they say I can't I
can't I can't tell you more but it
created a very very rich dialogue
immensely rich richer that we ever
imagined it would be and as you're
sitting in these people and you're
having this intense emotional
conversation one things that happens is
that with rare exception you fall in
love with the person you're interviewing
means it's really special people anyway
these are people who when most doctors
walked away committed themselves to for
whatever reason and which was one of the
things we want to see to working with
AIDS patients and of course people
present themselves in the best light so
I think one of the problems we had in
writing the book was here we have these
people who have really given us a gift
taken they're immensely busy people
taking our time to speak to us for four
hours six hours in one case eight hours
and who are quite lovely and gave us
these fantastic interviews they're just
wonderful people
how can you be critical how do you
criticize these people have you we
didn't want to write a you know
hagiography so how can you add once how
can you be in historian how can you be
have that kind of critical historical
posture in this kind of situation and
I'll tell you a little while how we how
we manage how we dealt with that so we
interviewed people these were physicians
from all over the country eventually in
his 76 doctors mainly on the two coasts
but also there's Cleveland Chicago
Austin Texas cities in in the midwest
and the south some of them we
interviewed twice some of them three
times we start our interviews at the end
of 1995 we finished our interviews
around night September 1997 I when we
started we really had no idea where this
book was going to go I was going to end
and we really had no idea about how we
were going to use the oral history when
we began in 1995 we were in what one of
the physicians call the middle ages of
the AIDS epidemic this was a period if
you know the history of Asia of it was a
period where there was a deep
disappointment with the first
antiretroviral AZT there was a sense
that they would have ten years in the up
into the epidemic there were there was
no
vacations available that could directly
successfully limit or the virus that
what doctors had learned painfully
painstakingly over those years was how
to deal with the opportunity infections
that were secondary to the virus and its
destruction of the immune system one
good piece of news as I recall was that
there had been a clinical trial Oh 76
out in California which had demonstrated
that if you gave a ziti two women in the
third trimester and to the newborn that
you could reduce the mother to child
transmission of the virus by two-thirds
which was impressive it was one good
piece of news in that period uh any case
we we had no idea where this what was
going and how is going to end what the
arc of the book would be we did have
themes in our in a questionnaire um like
you know why you know why did well why
do people commit themselves to to the
epidemic what was it like to be in days
doctor when he couldn't do a great deal
for treating impotence so we hadn't goat
but I'll go through all the themes we
had themes the questions were clustered
around these domains or themes but what
what happened during the history of this
project was that was unbeknownst to us
that by the end of butt end of 1996
a new class of drugs would be announced
of antiretrovirals that in fact would
were quite effective and imparting cause
there were a number of them AZT it
wasn't that was ineffective but it was a
single drug and this virus mutated so
quickly that viral resistance developed
very fast whereas if you gave multiple
drugs you could slow down the you can
slow that down and there were other
classes of drugs you could give and so
with that the interesting pharmacology
changed the whole tenor and face and
feeling of hiv/aids whereas it was aids
was a almost uniformly fatal disease or
once people were diagnosed they they
died a dependent which period talking
about within a year or two years three
years AIDS now became a disease that
could be managed and people could live
for decades and they didn't have to be
micromanage the way they had previously
and it dramatically changed the disease
and it dramatically changed the
relationship between doctors and
patients number of doctors retire there
went to different things they could
finally leave aids care after almost 20
years whereas they couldn't do that
before because they would be leaving
dying patients and now AIDS was a normal
disease they could move on so that
presented an interesting arc and in fact
athlete interviews in order to capture
that new period we did a number of
interviews by phone with maybe a dozen
doctors and we sent out a survey
instrument
to get the response of doctors to this
whole new regime and then what are we
going to do with all these tapes all
these transcripts we didn't know one
thing we knew was we weren't going to
use these programs that sociologists use
to try to get key terms and it didn't
feel right as a historian it just seemed
too mechanical and so we fell back on
something very old-fashioned that I've
been trained in Ron been trained in
textual analysis we just in other words
we read and took notes we read over and
over again and the first time we went
through these transcripts certain things
began to emerge and to arrange
themselves so it's okay we started to
outline a book and you said okay but how
we going to do this and we hit upon this
very you know again traditional method
we had a sense of what each chapter what
the themes of each chapter would be so
we set up spreadsheets for each chapter
quite hard copy spreadsheets what do we
know and the rows were the physicians
the 76 doctors and the columns were
broad themes and we went through all the
transcripts again and anytime the theme
came up not because it was a keyword but
because we can see the thing we wrote
down in the cell doctor theme the pages
of the transcript and that became
essentially our guide to the transcripts
and as we worked on this and became
clear to us what the book would look
like that we were privileged to have the
voice of powerful interesting voices of
these doctors speaking out about
incredible things and consequently it
seemed to us that while we had a story
in sense of the history of the epidemic
of course we would not be writing a
history of the epidemic we will be
writing a history of the experiences of
these doctors faced with a disease of
unknown origin the experience of the
doctors as doctors as human beings
living through living in this epidemic
in which the beginning they didn't know
whether they themselves like doctors of
treating tuberculosis or plague years
before right themselves died of the
epidemic transmitted by their own
patients uh dealing with issues and
these are the chapters the broad
chapters quickly dealing with the issues
of discovery there's an epidemic having
your first patience and commitment why
did you commit this to me was a critical
question when people were not committing
why did these doctors commit and not
just for a year is easy or easier to
commit yourself for a few months but
these were people who commit themselves
for a decade or longer that's pretty
amazing considering the how horrible of
the disease was and the emotional
demands it made on doctors the second
chapter we call the dark years fear
impotence and rejection this was a
period during the 1980s in particular
where a doctor to know what to do and
basically they they were living in a
state of fear the fear was
doctor said that they might get sick
that they had nothing to offer their
patients that in fact some they were
killing their patients not because I
wanted but because as one doctor said
you know when when all you have is a
hammer the whole world is a nail so if
you were an oncologist what you knew was
chemotherapy people will people were die
of kaposi's sarcoma cancer give them
chemotherapy totally destroyed the
immune system they died and rejection in
that their colleagues and their
administrators at hospitals were
rejecting the Amazon hospitals all
across the country public hospitals
wells private hospitals people did not
want aids patients in those early years
and they didn't want the doctors to
bring them in and then the next chapter
therapeutic strivings third who stumbles
where these doctors are just starting to
develop clinical responses and starting
to experiment with very toxic drugs that
are kill the virus in the test tube and
try to see whether it works in their
patients culminating with the AZT trials
and frankly when there is nothing else
as when dr. berty you know and when
there's nothing else clayville trials
treatment too because it's only rings
and then the fourth chapter travel
agents of death and this is what really
discuss is one of the most powerful
parts of the book i think you know talk
about this a little bit and that's the
way doctors dealt with death these were
doctors who were trained in the
antibiotics era it's not that they
didn't see patients die but often they
were not there where the patients died
they were they they focused on managing
chronic disease but also curing patients
but to have as one doctor did 500 of his
patients
in a closed medical practice die is
carnage you nobody is trained to to deal
with that and and and that becomes very
very powerful and then the last chapter
is called the waning of the epidemic ?
was it really declining and that the
epilogue which dealt with in the story
of the protease inhibitors and how
doctors were moving on and so we
constructed this narrative where we
introduced each of these chapters set up
the issues and then use the voices of
the doctors almost like conversation in
which they discuss the various
dimensions of these issues and sub
issues so that gives a kind of rich
conversation and it was there going back
to issue I raised earlier it was there
that we could we could be critical of
our doctors by having other doctors say
things that contradicted or that
criticized a physician in a very
powerful way and then we could we could
elaborate on that in the text and that
we felt comfortable in doing that and
how long I've been talking but it's
great okay oh I what I thought I would
do in talk about this a is dawkins book
is just give you a little taste of the
book of how we proceeded looking at the
chapter on on
death and dying I'm just giving you some
of that and in the beginning we you know
we did number of things and we mentioned
the fact which is critical that none of
these doctors were really trained to
deal with death let alone five hundred
deaths may this wonderful dr. Lisa
capellini out in San Francisco saying I
remember very early in med school having
a sense that something was wrong insofar
as it was clear treatment wasn't working
but we didn't deal with it very upfront
nor were we as doctors very good about
comforting our patients and their
families it was just a sort of sense of
embarrassment or anger at the patients
dying and there really wasn't a sense of
death as part of all our lives and I
treating someone with great care and
skill is as important as when someone's
in the intensive care unit and getting
very technically complex treatment that
at the point of death you want to do the
sink sort of thing and then we have John
Missoula again talking about how how
they dealt with death and dying and
psychologically prepare themselves for
as well as preparing the patience for it
and John Missoula finally said you could
do everything right not smoke run go to
the gym eat take your AZT DDI or
whatever you're in sick LaVere go to
every doctor's appointment be a goody
two-shoes and you still die everybody
knows when they come in here that I'm
not going to save them that's not the
point of coming to see dr. Missoula
I am NOT going to save you we're going
to use every tool at Western and Eastern
and God knows what medicine has we're
going to do it but you're still going to
die it was the message the doctors had
to learn and that they had to give to
their patients and so these doctors in
since they went in order to acquit
themselves both in terms of not being
able to treat and having a lot of
patients die they then since went back
historical they said well what do
doctors do it was one doctor said they
get biblical reference he said they've
been doctors around for five thousand
two hundred years we've only been able
to treat patients for the last 100 years
what do doctors do though the previous
five thousand one hundred years and it
was basically holding him being there
being warm giving hope making people
comfortable and part of that became part
of that treatment became trying to help
people to die and doctors began to
develop this notion of the good death
that these people were dying a horrible
disease of a stigmatized disease in a
place in the beginning were nurses and
other doctors wouldn't even come into
their rooms let alone touch them and
they were going to create a special
place and this ends death was going to
be a meaningful death and so we have
Jerry friesland who at that time of this
quote was a doctorate in the Bronx at
Mont if you are working with IV drug
users
I even middle-class patients and he said
we would preside over their cruel deaths
and in his stigmatized unknown disease
it was quite a trick but I got very good
at organizing people's deaths and is
very complicated and painful and unknown
situation you've got to get this person
to be at peace with himself or herself
and deal with issues of blame and guilt
and death and dying I learned to talk to
people about it i learned to use Claude
realized something I've never done in my
career and I learned to work with groups
and then of course doctors had to learn
how to deal with families if they were
family is available and how to get them
to see that the person was dying there
were all kinds of aspects of death and
dying that they had to learn and so one
of the things I've AIDS did in changing
medicine at least temporarily was for
those doctors who are invested in the
epidemic was to become much more
conscious of their role as physicians in
the dying process and some of them
actually start working hospice as a
consequence of that and we have this I
just read this to these other quotes to
you we have this narrative this is
Joseph O'Neill who at that time was a
medical student at San Francisco General
Hospital since gone on to become a very
famous age doctor and he talks about an
early patient of his he was very sick he
was wasted it was paraplegic and just
awful pain here's a gay man living in
San Francisco his parents lived in
Florida they came out in total denial of
what
going on they love the sky their son
passionately and all they wanted to do
was to fix everything and they wanted
the best doctors everything that money
could buy and what does dr. Valle
buildings say about this after all
bidding being one of the great a doctors
and what does so and so think I mean
very kind of controlling behavior or
like he wanted chocolate pudding in the
centum Pease pudding I'm going to call
the head of the hospital they were very
hard to deal with it could imagine these
are real linux and here i am this
medical student working with a resident
who wasn't even paying much attention to
the patient because he was no longer and
interesting can you see was dying and
the patient was very much the same way
like his parents you know this room is
too bright i asked for water and I
didn't get ice I wanted ice so he's a
kind of Jewish Prince and meanwhile
here's a skinny dying young man who's
worried about the flavor of his pudding
you know I mean the whole thing was
wrong I remember this this is where I
really learned something about doctoring
from him one morning I was just talking
with him it's sort of listening and he
looked at me and he said am I going to
die and I said yes you're going to die
and he said when and I said very soon
and he asked to my parents know about
this and I said I think they do but you
have to talk to them about it and he
said no no I couldn't talk to him about
it it's too hard and I said when your
parents get here today you have the
nurse page me and I'll come and about an
hour later we were rounding and I got
paged by the nurse saying that the
parents were there I came back down I
walked in the room and they would just
say all this stuff and the whole time I
had never seen one of his parents touch
him or lay hands on him in the three
weeks they were there I mean they did
everything but they were running around
they were fixing the blinds I remember
they were fixing the blinds in his room
and I went out and I Vorian chairs these
folding chairs and I set up the chairs
around the bed and I said stop it I mean
it was just me no nurse no one else just
me this little medical student you know
and I said sit down we have something
very important to discuss here and so
they sat down and it said what we have
to discuss is the fact that your son is
dying and I said I just want you to talk
about it so I'll leave the room if you
want but this is what's happening
there's nothing more we going to do your
son is dying and you really need to
spend some time with him and remember
his parents they started crying and they
got up and they held him and in three
weeks they had never touched him and I
left and I said you have to say goodbye
it doesn't matter what he's eating it
matters that you spend some time
together and it was called that night
maybe two hours after they left he died
so I'll end with that and this is why
yes it's there just powerful powerful
discussions like that and you can see
why we used the voices of the doctors to
the force of that to narrate the book so
i'll talk a little bit about the next
book just to touch on it we thought we
were done you know Rhonda had they work
in the AIDS epidemic for 18 years like
the doctors in the book we thought we go
on to do something else and then in the
year 2000 ah there was an Internet the
International AIDS meetings which occur
every two years took place for the first
time in Africa and they were in durban
south
ago and that was meeting where people
became outside Africa became aware of
the depth of the epidemic in on that
continent that were San Francisco in New
York to us looking inside our country
will the epicenter of the epidemic in
fact the epidemic the epicenter has
shifted outside of the Western outside
of the west and was now in sub-saharan
Africa where about seventy-five percent
of the cases occurred and the epicenter
of that was South Africa and we were
stunned to learn that at that time 2000
about 5 to 6 million people in South
Africa the population of about I don't
know 46 million people or HIV positive
and as we learn more first one of our
first trips we took four trips to South
Africa there were parts of one province
called kwazulu-natal which is what
Durban is which had the highest rates of
infection that there were prenatal
clinics where forty percent or fifty
percent of the women visiting the
prenatal clinics who are hiv-positive
imagine that was stunning that something
under half the women in these areas were
already hiv-positive ah and of course
when you hear something like that what
to do something and in fact some of the
doctor is like Jerry friedland who i
quoted already in Africa they had lucky
night they had left the United States
but they started working in African
countries where the epidemic felt like
the epidemic in the 1980s in
in the Bronx so what Quran and I do you
wouldn't want to screen patients where
stories and ethicists so we decided
we're going to come out of retirement
doesn't work we've been retired for
about four days and we were going to
we're going to become witnesses as we
had of this merkin epidemic we're gonna
become witnesses of the epidemic in
South Africa this is a time when the New
York Times did not have correspondents
in South Africa people were not
interested in Africa and we thought we
had to get the word out of what was
happening in South Africa so of we began
a new project and the outcome of that
new project is this second book well
shattered dreams in oral history of the
South African aids epidemic ah the title
comes from a speech by many Chris honey
who if he had lived if he had had been
assassinated by South African Police
probably would have become the second
president of South Africa after Mandela
because he was so popular he was
charismatic he was a leader of the
military wing of the African National
Congress the leading liberation party
and he was General Secretary of the
Communist Party in South Africa and the
liberation movement was essentially had
three legs was the it was the African
National Congress of which Mandela was
the initial ahead the Communist Party
which supported them since the 1940s 115
and the trade union movement in South
Africa these are basically the ruling
groups today so Chris Hani at a meeting
in Mobutu in 1990 meeting
which was set up to deal with a the
health issues that would they would have
to deal with when they took over in
South Africa said we have a noble task
ahead of us reconstruction of our
country we cannot afford to allow the
AIDS epidemic to Arun the realization of
our dreams so he understood that the
AIDS epidemic this is in 1990
represented and recipient threat to
South Africa and but nobody did anything
and so by the time Mandela is elected in
1994 there are there's already an
enormous epidemic in South Africa where
I mean no one knows the numbers inside
of AIDS in a reportable disease in South
Africa but is a 4 million 5 million
people wore a Chevy positive enormous
number of people so you can say that is
epidemic appoint was one of the
consequences of the apartheid regime
that was then carried over into the new
dispensation onda Mandela so one of the
things that we tried to do is spoke of
courses to describe through the doctors
and nurses we really did the same things
before we interview doctors from all of
us out the Africa every racial group
every specialty soon as did in the
United States
almost all the geographic areas urban
town mine countryside doctors to get
their experience of the hiv/aids
epidemic there so through these doctors
trying to get a sense of what it means
to have five or six million people
infected but
this book also is a very political book
the a doctor's book instance is an
internal history of the AIDS epidemic as
experienced by physicians which is not
to say there aren't political issues or
ethical issues as part of their practice
but there have been other books written
about the politics of AIDS in South
Africa first of all we write for an
American audience that doesn't know
about the politics in South Africa
second you're talking about an epidemic
which came out of the apartheid era and
this has to be a book about politics
about about as it turns out about ethics
and in addition to describing the force
of the epidemic and its effect on the
healthcare system I think what this book
is is a book about inequity and
inequality the first book i think is a
book about commitment it to me it's it's
like writing a book about the resistance
in Second World War why did some people
in 1940 become resistance people and
what was their experience of the next
five years with their life in danger
here this is a book about inequity and
inequality on multiple levels of theirs
domestic inequality along with Ames the
new dispensation on the middle also
inherited a two-tier medical system
there's a private sector and a public
sector and say about the private sector
you could be sitting in a hospital in
the private sector and you can be in a
hospital in Cleveland you can be a
hospital in Rochester New York you
wouldn't know you're in South Africa ah
the private sector is one thing and you
can get the same medical care the same
drugs as you could get in the United
States but you have to have the money or
health insurance that covers that the
public sector is where the majority of
the population is treated and that has
been traditionally underfunded course
under apartheid the funding was channel
on the basis of rates of the best
hospitals like Naruto Sakura which was a
world-class hospital like Belgium was
for whites and then there were less
their hospitals for Indians of the worst
hospitals for Africans and the urban
hospitals men in the rural hospital but
essentially the public hospitals are
where the poor which is say the majority
of people with AIDS who are very large
like Africans were treated and you're
pretty aware outside of Goethe Sakura
that you're in the third world medical
system and so this is a system that
people went to when they started coming
down with AIDS and very quickly these
hospitals began filling up and just as
quickly they had to keep people out
because if they took all the people in
the awards one would be indicated that
wars would be like the Lord's work years
ago and this find it that's sort of in
yet i Henry Sun path was an Indian
doctor in a missionary X missionary
Hospital in Durban he talks about his
first experiences of AIDS and he was
working he was working in an X Indian
hospital or maybe it still wasn't Indian
hospital in Durban and he said people
used to becoming instructors from all
over the outlying areas of Durban
absolutely sick dehydrated vomiting
hardly able to breathe and their entire
communities used to be coming along with
them saying please please help this
person do something and there was no
mechanism in that hospital to take these
patients in sort them out medically to
equip them with knowledge or the means
to go back home and take care of
themselves the hospital was so
overwhelmed with a number of these
patients that at the emergency level
itself the basic minimum was done and
they were asked to go back home it was
devastating I used to go back home and
tell my wife I just don't know what to
do that showed me the extent to which I
really needed to get involved because it
was just so hopeless looking at the
faces of these people near death and
just looking and they were just looking
at you to do something so these are
public hospitals then just kind of take
these patients are just too many
so this state's very stark for you the
difference between the haves and the
have-nots those who had money or had
health insurance had access to
antiretrovirals where are these book
ends by night by 2000 if you would leave
the United States certainly be lived in
the UK and had HIV you had access
antiretrovirals in South Africa you had
access antivirals only if you get to the
private hospitals and as one doctor said
you know if you you're rich man you can
buy a Mercedes if you're poor man you
can buy pair of shoes with AIDS if
you're a rich man you live and if you're
a poor man you're done there's that
start but then there were other issues
of inequality that this rings which
people are just starting to think about
and that is why is it that we accept the
fact that there are not antiretrovirals
in developing countries something we
just so for granted
why do Western countries or the
pharmaceutical companies which are
primarily our Western price their drugs
in such a way that they don't make them
available to developing countries is
this equitable is this fair should
people in develop in in the developing
world just died because they were denied
Adan a fortunate to be born in poor
countries so that raised a lot of very
important issues in the late 1990s
including in South Africa where the drug
companies were try to prevent the
government from importing
antiretrovirals cheaply from India or
buying through us other countries
middlemen and then a third issue
occurred with South Africa this is
before 2000 at the meeting in Durban in
addition to learning about the the
burden of the epidemic the scientists
they are signed a petition against this
the stance of the president of South
Africa people not the virus and that all
we were doing by using a treasure
islands was enriching the first world
pharmaceutical companies who probably
were responsible for propagating this
idea that a virus caused the disease and
so I'm Becky
we've used to allow antiretrovirals into
the public sector again the private
sector anything you want perhaps the
answer retrovirus were too expensive in
the ninth in the early in the late 1990s
but by 2000 the price was coming down
substantially and in fact some of the
drug companies actually offering South
Africa some of the drugs like nevirapine
for free and still the government
rejected their offers and so in certain
ways I'm claim this exacerbated the
inequality because only people who could
access the private sector somehow could
get drugs and so it's this whole theme
of inequality that plays out in this
book and how physicians in South Africa
many of whom had been involved in the
anti-apartheid movement were members of
the African National Congress had to
deal with working within the public
sector had to deal with the inequalities
and the rationing of the public sector
accommodate themselves to that
accommodate themselves not only to the
fact that most of their colleagues did
not want to touch an AIDS patient but
that they still believed that there was
nothing you could do in the year 2000
2001 we actually are that there was
nothing you could do for AIDS patients
which is nonsense and you just let them
die and then how do you deal with your
government which you support it
everywhere voted for Mandela when they
take the stance and how do you create
islands of resistance how did these
doctors over the early 2000s do what
what the treatment action campaign
wanted what what up act up used to say
get drugs into bodies
and this is what this is the story in
this book until there is kind of day new
amount of course of one that we could
not know and that was in 2003 and Beck a
step back and finally allowed his
government to begin planning the rollout
retrovirus to the population which was
done at a glacial pace because his
Minister of Health did not believe in
natural retroviral zand was said
advocating the African potato garlic and
olive oil as nostrils for treating HIV
so that when we ended the book in 2006
the rollout was occurring but at this
glacial pace where people essentially
were treating the patients they knew but
new out there outside their clinics
there were millions of people who they
who were not being treated so so that
there was this kind of optimism yes we
can do something about this kind of
pessimism that what we're doing is I'm a
drop in the ocean and oh I've spoke too
long going to end right there and thank
you for your attention and take any
questions thank you so much